the final story for today is an
extension of something we've been
talking about the last couple days
whoopi goldberg
goldberg
goldberg
has been
suspended by abc
because of some comments that she made
about holocaust the holocaust
and the jews
goldberg
goldberg got some info from the
associated press whoopi goldberg was
suspended for two weeks tuesday as
co-host of the view because of what the
head of abc news called her wrong and
hurtful comments about jews and the
holocaust while whoopi has apologized
i've asked her to take time to reflect
and learn about the impact of her
comments the entire abc news
organization stands in solidarity with
our jewish colleagues friends and family
and communities abc news president kim
godwin said in a statement my words
upset so many people which was never my
intention she said tuesday morning i
understand why now
and for that i am deeply deeply grateful
because the information i got was really
helpful and helped me understand
some different things so first i just
want to reiterate something that i said
yesterday which is that i do not think
that uh whoopi goldberg
who chose her name
chose her name her stage name whoopi
goldberg her real name is i said karen
walker yesterday but it's not karen
walker it's
karen johnson
uh she chose her stage name because she
was actually very influenced by a lot of
jewish people when she was growing up
okay so it was an homage to these people
i don't think she's an anti-semite i
don't think she hates jews i think she's
very confused about what the nazis were
all about that they viewed jews as
another race
by the way judaism because it's a
religion and an ethnicity and a culture
we can talk about all of that stuff
related to race the problem here is that
because she's gone so in on the woke
ideology that puts skin color above
everything else she's having trouble
seeing that and she's just in over her
head but i but i don't think she hates
jews number one and i don't think
actually that suspending her now she got
suspended for two weeks paid so she's
gonna make money and sit at home and eat
bonbons and enjoy herself
but i don't think suspending her is the
right idea right if we're gonna if we're
gonna stand up against cancel culture if
we're gonna really try to work through
these issues honestly then what really
makes sense here like what is suspending
her for two weeks actually do like if
anything she's probably a little more
annoyed you've enraged some people who
are trying to understand the nuance of
the issue but why not have her on the
show today and have someone honestly
have a
say a holocaust historian or a
sociologist
on the show to explain some of that
stuff i mean if you think this is
important to talk about right if abc
thinks this is so important that we
should spend her for saying what she
thinks however misguided why not use
this time when the when the magnifying
glass is on it right why not use it so
that you can educate her thus educating
other people but we do this very odd
thing no she must be removed from
society for two weeks and paid
i don't care about the paid or unpaid
but it just feels like nonsense and also
it's like you have to understand that
there's a there's a theater and a show
business version of this it's like if
you were whatever you do for a living
whatever you do for a living let's say
you're an accountant
right you're an account and you're in an
office of accountants and let's say one
of your the other accountants you guys
are by the water cooler do we have water
coolers anymore i'm not sure but you buy
the coffee machine i think we have those
still you're by the coffee machine and
one of the
accountants says something about the
holocaust that doesn't ring true and
then the other account and brings that
to hr and then hr's answer is you
accountant you will not crunch numbers
for the next two weeks you will go home
and you will get paid to do nothing for
two weeks and then you can come back to
work and everything's okay it's like
none of this really makes any sense
these these slap on the wrists odd
things but the unfortunate part here
really is that there was a teachable
moment and we sort of just went by that
teachable moment
fortunately though i know that you guys
don't watch the view except when i show
you clips of it and i apologize because
the view is on right now and you're
watching this
you're not watching the view